plenty of steps still to take to land
this crucial climate summit the
president how's it going these leaders
into final talks before bowing out of
glasgow
as the clock ticks down the decision
makers into the tunnel of negotiations
so much to do
but it's away from the cameras that
success is either nailed down or falls
down
slow but steady commitments from india
the foreign secretary convinced
reversing deforestation by 2030 an
important move it's still touch and go
but we have seen some positive leaves
particularly on forest president how's
it going is it going well it's going
well positive rumblings but so much more
to come the prime minister keeping the
suspense
how's it going
i'll be giving you a press conference a
bit later on
but before dealing with the media an
audience with president biden and other
leaders
using this opportunity to amplify a
domestic message
our pursuit of global net zero
can drive global leveling up are you
pleased with progress sir and it will be
these leaders driving it the ecuadorian
president seeming positive we're making
progress with actor and environmentalist
leonardo dicaprio bringing star power to
help project cop onto a truly global
stage
taken to his stage for the final time at
least for now the pm seemingly confident
i am cautiously optimistic
in the sense that
on the way to
the g20 in rome i said to some of you on
the plane that if this was a football
match then the current score would be
5-1 down
in the in the match between humanity and
climate change
and
i think what you could say today after
two days of
talks with around 120 world leaders
is that we've pulled back
a goal or perhaps even two
and i think we're going to be able uh to
take this thing to extra time
commitments on ending deforestation by
2030 japan committing 10 billion more in
climate aid cash india with a net zero
commitment by 2070 but there's at least
one elephant in the room to use your
football analogy you talked about being
able to equalize in extra time
but isn't the sad reality of all of this
that if china is not on the pitch
team world is not going to be able to
equalize
yes it's true that
president xi isn't isn't here but that
doesn't mean the chinese are not
engaging uh they've made the commitment
on uh on net zero by the middle of the
century by by 2060 or earlier can 1.5
stay alive if china doesn't move in the
next two weeks or you think they will i
i think that uh
we need china to to make
commitments do we need more progress you
bet we need more progress from from
china um and from and from everybody
here at this at this gathering
the prime minister always fond of an
analogy has described the battle against
climate change as a football match in
which team wilde is almost all but
defeated
now it seems that world leaders are
beginning to pull up their socks but as
he acknowledged in that closing press
conference china needs to begin to play
ball and as world leaders leave here and
their negotiators step in the hard
bargaining really begins
heading off but will things go the right
way everything still to play for beth
rigby sky news glasgow